good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
folklore friday friday
gonna get down on friday
it is a fabulous but rainy day here in
new york
it's so gloomy behind us it looks like
we're filming at night but we are
filming the same time but
as usual it's because god's crying at
how beautiful taylor swift's new album
is and i agree with him
it is beautiful god that's
beautiful he's setting the scene for the
mood of the day of listening to folklore
um we hope everyone had a great day we
have a fabulous show planned for you
guys it's
friday and you got any big weekend plans
i'm gonna be listening to folklore i
have a lot of tv to watch i have to read
the book for the redheads my dark
vanessa if you haven't started it yet it
is never too late to join the redheads
did you know that
because you could always start on this
month's episode it's so true or you
could
go all the way back and catch up with us
like we're always there waiting for you
always and if you're looking for a fun
and educational thing to do during
quarantine the redheads
is that thing for you now let me ask you
it's been you know a couple months since
you started your passion project and
how's it going i still am feeling deeply
passionate about it
that's by the way that's so important
and you know quarantine was an
interesting time for the redheads
because we doubled up to two books a
month
i remember then we scaled it back once
things started to go back a little bit
to normal
but we were recording over zoom which
made it a lot more difficult
but this month we are recording it
together
in the studio for the first time in
months so i'm just so excited to see
where the conversation goes
i haven't started the book yet but i've
heard a lot of different things about it
i think it's a very
intense book thanks dana uh so
i gotta i gotta get into it well i too
have a lot to do this weekend you know
i'm just so busy like so many plans
people keep inviting me places
and it's just it really is hard to be
like this quarantined socialite but you
know i'm making the best
and doing the most that i can i will be
home all weekend doing absolutely
nothing i do have some tv to watch i
need to watch our toast movie of the
week which is
black panther which we'll be recapping
on monday also i think the kissing booth
comes out this weekend the sequel so
i'm going to be watching that i'm going
to finish the crown
um i'm just looking forward to spending
some real quality time with my bed even
though i do that
pretty much every day it hits different
on the weekends it hits different on the
weekends and
sleeping in it's so different in
quarantine like i just count down i live
five days for the two that i can sleep
in thousand
i wake up five mornings for two yeah
because there is
literally nothing quite like waking up
without an alarm waking up and like for
a second you're like do you have to work
and then it hits you that it's like
saturday or sunday flip back over on the
other side of the bed
take it out hopefully your husband
already woke up and is in the living
room
and you're just sprawled city it's
it's incomparable to any real feeling in
the world better
better than my wedding day honestly like
i work so hard and just like
live my whole life for that moment you
know 100 percent
everything that i do is to make that
moment better you know take
my worries away so when i flip over
nothing's creeping into my mind
and that's the smooth sounds of sleep
that's what life is all about like those
little moments yeah you know
and you do all the rest of it to make
sure those little moments are as
fabulous as they can be
so i'll be just like experiencing
moments this weekend like that's what
i'm going to be really busy doing and
i'm
so thrilled about it yeah i'm i'm super
thrilled and like if anything comes in
the way of me and that's really
why i have such a complicated
relationship with drinking because
it [ __ ] with my sleep but sleep is the
most
important thing to me but what
complicates is it's that like you work
so hard like let me celebrate with a
bottle of wine they're so similar but
they are constantly contradicting each
other that is
very true so that's why it's all you
know
it's like a science no it's it's really
like a balance it's a balancing act for
sure
and you know they say that life is a
balance so i guess that's what they were
talking about
yeah like drinking enough but you can
still sleep through the night without
your body
being dehydrated and waking itself up
yeah like at 8am
okay so if you guys have figured out the
trick to balancing
please let us know please let us know we
have a great show t.h.e.o is here and he
chose to sit with his auntie today
so hurtful i know it's hurtful but like
you get him 100 of the time so this is
so special for me so i just have like
i just have so much more love in my
heart to give yeah you know i feel that
and i'm i'm looking forward to getting
his thoughts on folklore
folklore real housewives of new york and
beverly hills recap a little bit since
you didn't get a chance to watch
yesterday and
is that it i guess so i guess we just
got right in because i think the only
thing we really want to talk about today
is folklore
so without further ado it is time for
the fast five stories that you need to
know yep you
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and that's true
one thousand percent you did you lie no
but i think maybe you forgot that today
is friday
and what we've been doing for the last
couple fridays is highlighting black
owned businesses and i am so excited
about today's
because not only is it a black-owned
business it is a black
toaster-owned business called august
onset
when newly engaged toaster elena
congrats congrats and her fiance shawn
found themselves cooped up quarantining
at her parents house they quickly needed
new activities to keep them occupied
they ended up looking into candle making
for a fun and relaxing date night at
home
they ordered supplies opened the wine
and found themselves lost in creating
scents and discovering the perfect
combinations
after honing all the plainly toasty
vibes elena's finished product quickly
caught the attention of her family
members with their warm welcoming and
unique aromas
she started creating candles for her
friends extended family members and
members of her community receiving
dozens of new requests
as more and more people found out about
her candles before they knew it elena
and sean were spending hours making
batches of candles
sending them to anyone who asked and
anyone who knew they needed a pick-me-up
together they created august onset
assorted candles luxury candles at an
affordable price
how many times have you been strolling
the aisles of an overpriced store
and or home goods you know no shade but
that is one of my favorite stores
um when the inviting scent of a
delicious seasonal candle stops you in
your tracks
you say to yourself i need this candle
but then you look at the price only to
be shocked and disappointed why is this
candle expensive as [ __ ]
you do try to justify it but you end up
putting it back down knowing that it's
ridiculous and not worth it
august onset on the other hand will not
disappoint they offer the perfect candle
chic affordable and convenient with
scents that permeate the whole room
without overpowering it
august onset was created by a passionate
toaster with the goal of giving you a
little piece
of your much-needed spa vacation without
breaking the bank
august onset knows that these times have
been tough for everyone offering
relaxing aromas with calming effects to
bring you and your family peace
joy and positivity when you need it most
august onset provides premium quality
hand crafted homemade candles
their hand poured products are made with
all natural soy wax
and infused with organic essential oils
committed to delivering quality products
that are crafted with care
august onset promises white glove
customer service with 24 hour email and
phone support ensuring that your
shopping experience is seamless
from checkout to delivery they're sought
after for signature scents
spa day fresh cut gardenia ocean tide
and brandy pair
are perfect for any occasion and offer
something unique and special for
everyone
whether you're working remotely living
in close quarters with your in-laws or
just plain bored we could all use a
boost
if you're spending all of your time at
home why not make it smell great that's
why we love august onset
they make quarantining a little bit more
bearable taking you away with their
captivating scents and transporting you
with their warm spa-like feel
indulge in self-care or send a smile to
a loved one with an august onset candle
extravagance and warmth of a high-end
candle without being overpriced
jackie and i got all four candles first
of all i'm really weird about candles
um these smell fantastic and they're
sickeningly stunning like matte black
they're just sick and gotta support
toaster on businesses you guys
you can find august onset assorted sense
on instagram
at august like the month on set
o-n-s-e-t
and shop their products at
augustonset.com again that's
www.augustonset.com
luxury candles at an affordable price
thank you
elena and sean um everyone's supporters
excited
me too okay i'm sorry you were saying
first story
folklore has dropped what are our
initial
thoughts oh my god there's so many like
i truly don't know what to say take it
from the top and take your time
you're our resident stan and we want to
hear from you so at midnight i watched
the cardigan music video first
and i always find it really interesting
the songs that taylor chooses to either
like make music videos for or make
singles because i don't usually agree
with the selection and i do feel the
same way about cardigan
um it wasn't the song that like i was
immediately drawn to
on the album but she has her ways and
will figure out like what what the point
was the music video was
sickeningly stunning and filled with
metaphors like the piano just kept
saving her life which is like
so taylor like the music saves her and i
was really impressed that they were able
to put it together
um during quarantine be and clearly so
fast because it was like
mystically it was just visually stunning
with the ocean and the ferry and the
piano
bench like it was just beautiful um but
i felt very anxious because i didn't
know if i should listen to the album
or watch a music video live on youtube
but did you watch live with the other
fans
yes honestly it was annoying because
every time i turned my phone to the side
i kept getting people's comments and it
was like
flooding so fast and it was taking up
half the screen that's so annoying you
should have watched on your tv or
oh totally or just my computer um but it
was a really fabulous well done music
video
um and then i went into the album and
the first thing i noticed about the
album well first of all i could not find
it on itunes but it was it's on itunes
this morning but itunes just took a long
time
spotify there's an explicit explicit
version she curses a lot
really yes because it opens with a curse
on some new [ __ ]
yeah but then there was more like i
actually was like
it's kind of remember when we were
recapping lover and we were talking
about
soon you'll get better and we were
talking about the line i pray to jesus
and it's just like i never thought i
would hear taylor swift
say jesus like i know she's catholic or
christian but like i just never thought
there would come a day where i heard
taylor swift say jesus
um and that's how i feel about like her
cursing it just it feels
so different but i don't dislike it i
like it a lot
what i noticed first was that the album
was released as an alternative album
like in the alternative genres which
makes
makes this the third genre she has
conquered and i just think that's so
impressive
you know this whole thing is just so
impressive to me like
the genre the songwriting like i mean
that's always been like her thing and
like what she has in my opinion over
other artists is her ability to like
storytell and write songs about like
things that might not even be about her
like the last great american dynasty
which i believe is about the couple who
lived in her rhode island house before
she bought it yes it's like
i mean that's what it sounds like from
the lyrics yeah and it's just like
to me and i was like going so hard with
ben last night like just being like you
believe like she wrote a song about that
he was like yeah it's great but to me
like that is so impressive to be able to
like storytell
about something that has nothing to do
with you is crazy yeah um
and another thing that stood out to me
is that we have a full-blown
country song on the album and it's betty
like there's
like a banjo like it's
what we've been waiting for i mean i've
been waiting for like a whole country
album but you know us country stands
we'll take what we can get from taylor
swift
there is like a full-blown country song
um and it really sounds like her old
school like tim mcgraw
vibes and i'm just like living for it
when i first listened to an album i have
such a hard time like differentiating
what song is which
yeah they are very similar it's a
similar aesthetic for all of them but
that's what makes a great album
right um some of the immediate standouts
to me are elicit affairs which is just
so beautifully written
even though i don't know if taylor swift
has ever been in an affair because
that's so not her but maybe she has who
knows um
illicit affair stands out betty stands
out the last great american dynasty
stands out
um seven stands out
there's i really don't know the album
well enough to like make grand
statements and i don't want to do that i
just want to say
that it's really beautiful and coming
off of lover which was like so pop
so dancy ben was like where's the fast
songs i'm like this is an album ben
like pay attention please no
he was frustrating me so much last night
finally he fell asleep um
but and that was great like for lover
like there was dance pop like it was so
much
and now this is a total departure from
that this is very much like a massage
playlist
um and i love that for her i love slow
songs honestly i like songs slow songs
just as much as i like fast songs
yeah and some vibes require slow music
um
and i just i think it's really really
beautiful but i don't i haven't spent
i've only listened to it one and a half
times fully
um i haven't spent enough time to like
make grand statements on it but it's
beautiful
yes it's beautiful so is it what you
expected or way different
completely different really well i
didn't even know what to expect i got no
warning like all day yesterday i i had
no idea
it wasn't really what i expected but i
thought that you made a great
observation yesterday
saying that it would be a lot of archer
vibes because i agree it was very
archery like it does
a lot of the songs feel like 80s like
ballads which is always what i thought
about archer when i was listening
to august which is one of my favorite
songs it was starting to remind me of
like
90s music where it was like very you
know
whiny yeah or was like
i will go down yes
[ __ ] yes 100 like atlantis
so she has the same engineer or
something as lana del rey's norman
[ __ ] rockwell album and i definitely
and
lana del rey is like the alternative
artist i believe so
there are definitely um like nods of
lana del rey in there and it's just a
total departure from anything taylor's
ever done it's not country it's not pop
it's a whole different genre and it's
just
to me like it's just the whole thing is
like hi i'm taylor swift and like i put
this album together in three seconds and
like
here's why i'm impressive like the whole
thing is just very impressive to me like
a total different genre how fast it was
done the storytelling like the lyrics
to me like her and casey mouse graves
are the greatest lyricists of our time
in the way they tell stories and have
the ability to like some like with some
of them
the songs i really felt like i was
watching a movie like i was picturing it
all in my head
like her in rhode island or this random
couple in rhode island like
it it she has an uncanny ability to like
paint a picture with words which is
unfortunately not something i can do but
it's really a major talent
yeah i'm i'm like three quarters of the
way through the album
it's just an easy enjoyable listen yeah
but you know what it's like as much as
she's changing and it's now black and
white and it's you know this whole new
vibe and it's
alternative like it's so tailored to me
you know and i feel like i was expecting
something completely different like even
her using more instruments or like
synths that sound more like of the music
that's being made today
like lennon stella vibes but no it's
just
it's her you know she can't help but be
herself
and that's why we love her and that's
why like her country albums her pop
albums and her now alternative album
all have the same like dna even though
they sound and look completely different
um but speaking of the instruments what
i found to be so interesting was the
broad range of instruments
like reputation was very electric like
made on a laptop
and to me this was like made in a grassy
field with a banjo
there were so many strengths on her
guitar yeah it was and i cannot wait to
hear some of these acoustic like
it's i just i feel like i can't even
speak on it like i don't know her that
well right now you know
i need more time yeah we knew you would
need time but we also love to get
initial thoughts the initial thoughts
are that it's just
it's such a treat it's a pleasure to
listen to and she's done it again it's a
treat it's a pleasure to listen to and
she has done it again
so well said jackie great well i'm happy
for you in the big day that you have
today
and the weekend where you'll get to
spend listening to it
a lot of people requested a snitch on
the toe situation today
and we tried to get her unfortunately
she
was too damn busy for us she was up all
night recording like youtube reactions
for her youtube channel which honestly i
can't wait to see
she's just so cute but she did
tentatively say she
she would come in on monday to show her
thoughts so
we could all have another discussion on
monday
with some of our more concrete thoughts
after spending the time i think that's
fair
i think that's fair as well okay next
story ellen degeneres in portia de
rossi's home was burglarized
do you hear this um no
the santa barbara county sheriff's
office is reporting that ellen in
porsche's montecito home was burglarized
on the 4th of july
quote high value jewelry and watches
were reportedly the items taken from the
home which deputies said was targeted
because of its status as a known home to
celebrities right forensic technicians
and detectives are apparently working
the scene the santa barbara
barber county sheriff's office also
tells keyt
that they're coordinating with other law
enforcement agencies to
ascertain if the montecito burglary may
be connected to other celebrity
break-ins in the area
bling ring someone call alexis nyers
yeah so is this the home where she's
been filming
i don't know you know like this kind of
doesn't surprise me that like ellen was
targeted because she's been like
being dragged in the media recently and
so
many so much of like the resentment
people have for her is that like she
tries to be relatable and she lives in
this palace in montecito and i've
actually seen pictures of this
house in montecito um being passed
around on twitter a lot recently
so it's like the home immediately became
a target when like ellen became like a
joke in the media
um and nobody deserves to be burglarized
burglary is wrong
and this is it's so scary like the
feeling of someone
being or having been in your home is my
worst
[ __ ] nightmare yeah for sure but if
this is the home she's been staying in i
guess if she wasn't there and it was
burglarized then she's not under house
arrest guys
oh very good call
montecito california right right right i
do think that's the home that she was
saying is
but there have been a reported string of
celebrity homes in la that have been hit
including atlantis marsett wow two times
we said the latter this morning
wow nicki minaj rihanna emmy rossum
jamie presley david spade and christina
milian have been targeted by the thieves
wow someone is trying to get a sofia
coppola movie made after them
and trying to take over um alexis
neyer's
legacy and it's not cool guys burglary's
not cool
no this is not cool even if it's a
famous person like it's it's not a
victimless crime you guys
not at all okay next story something
that people have been talking a lot
about um
didn't really care too much but here we
are larissa pippen
is speaking out amid her feud rumored
feud with kim kardashian
larsa pippen seemingly chimed in on
rumors she and kim kardashian are best
seized
no more this week fans noticed the kkw
beauty founder and her sisters courtney
and chloe do not follow larsa on
instagram
anymore in response to the social media
scuttlebutt larsa posted a cryptic
no alluding to her possible removal from
kim's inner circle
she wrote quote i woke up this morning
blessed and see that everybody is
focused on who i am following and who i
am not following on social media
i am focused on my children my new
fitness brand larsa pip and fitness
in my relationships in real life praying
that everybody finds peace in their own
lives and focus on what brings
them happiness okay i feel like this
isn't the first time
i've read this story that kim kardashian
unfollows larissa pippen
oh really yes and a while back people
were like kim's not following larsa
and i went to who kim follows and like
she follows a very
skeleton crew of people but it was even
at the same time when larson was on the
show
with them i don't think there's much
going on here other than
just like following her close family and
like
i totally disagree oh i totally disagree
i think there's something totally going
on here
and i read something i think on e news
yeah i read it too someone gave a
statement just being basically being
like no blood blood they're just like in
different
stages in their life kim is focusing on
all of her projects and getting her
family
healthy and lars is focusing on whatever
it is that she does
kim has been focusing on her various
projects and her family for the last 10
years no that was definitely a lie but i
100
in their own ways they both like weirdly
addressed it i definitely think there's
something going on
i don't think because they were like
ride or die she was like really inner
circle like
and for a long time and now that i think
about it like i haven't really seen
anything about her
and someone noticed that they all
unfollowed her there's weirdness there
there is weirdness kim hasn't followed
larsa for a long time and i know because
i checked a while ago
and she wasn't following her so she
didn't just unfollow her as far as
i'm concerned there's weirdness there
but i guess we'll we'll see if she's on
the next season of keeping up
yeah because she was a resident i think
that she
she's like a day one friend i and they
keep those people close i
agree there's nothing going on oh i
think there's something going on
especially given the fact that like she
is a day one friend
and i just think there's like
they both also connie tweeted just the
tweet
and then deleted it there's something
going on 100
i'm not really upset she's not my
favorite like kardashian inner circle
best friend i could live without her
i actually really like her the episode
where it was like a showdown between her
and sarah
in turks and caicos oh my god i was so
team larsa
i was team neither of them because
i didn't relate to either of them like
that girl sarah was like a little too
stuck up
and larsa was being like a little bit
too much of an animal i i
like i'm not an animal personally so
maybe that's why i can appreciate it in
others you know i am an animal and i
know my limits
and larsa totally crossed the line i
just like there's always one friend
who's an animal and she deserves respect
someone's got to do it yes i i agree
someone has to be the animal and
that is larceny when there's such like a
timid and shy and like reserved girl in
the group like you've got to
like know your place and like read the
room
i disagree that girl was being so
annoying and she did
like but she's like courtney's friend
and like that's what courtney is that
honestly that girl was a lot like
courtney it was literally like courtney
versus chloe larson
sarah was courtney vs chloe yeah that
was a good episode
i missed tv like i know i missed
kardashians
me too this season just like ripped in
half and now we're just like sitting
here
waiting okay speaking of tv caroline
stanberry has debuted her new man
on instagram you are obsessed with carol
obsessed with her when she was on ladies
of london i was definitely like into her
but like i have
you know the show has been cancelled i
have moved past it and i i don't really
turn around very often and if i do
honestly it's not to like checking on
caroline stanberry's love life i thought
she was married she was married
her and her husband chem have split
unfortunately they had a really cute
marriage but yesterday she posted on
instagram with her new man who's a
former pro soccer player oh
and he's really cute and i just
absolutely love her i've been following
her since ladies of london and
she's just like still so relevant
considering she's not on a television
show
yeah because she like hangs out at
lindsay's mykonos bar with nicole shares
everywhere she's also like you know like
she's such good friends with larsa is
she
yes they're always in dubai together and
then when she comes to l.a
when caroline comes to la she's always
with larsa so as
our resident caroline stan barry
um is she living in dubai or she is back
in london she's living in dubai
oh so she must have liked it even though
she moved there for her husband's work
yes but i think because the whole family
got
situated there right she wasn't gonna
move them again yeah and i think she
really likes it because she's always
doing fabulous things there
and she is like rich like european and
she that's
like that's where she needs to be in
dubai yeah but she's always traveling
you know yeah no
you know here she is on a helicopter
with her man the world oh he's cute
i told you the world is her home yeah
she's a citizen of the world
truly a global citizen she's a lady of
london but a citizen of the world i love
that that should be her
instagram bio totally no yeah i just i
don't really keep up with her um
from ladies of london who i weirdly do
keep up with is juliette
you do because she like really turned
like that
she was like a weenie on the show she
was so not memorable but she turned her
little stint on reality tv it's like a
full-blown career in fashion she's like
a well-respected blogger
in wherever she lives and she like goes
to a bunch of like paris
runway uh fashion week london milan
and i think it's impressive honestly the
whole cast was so iconic like
caprice caprice who was in the news
recently because she
went on a date with prince andrew and
she sat on the iron
at the iron throne on the throne
there was like it came out no no she
just like sat on the throne and she was
like in the castle
because she because prince andrew was
like trying to impress her yes and then
there's marissa hermer
oh yes who we met was so nice she's so
lovely and then there's you know
um there's the other caroline with a d
caroline fleming fleming who
because she's from denmark and she's
royalty so like always fabulous
and then there is the one hold on just
give me one minute because when i say
this you're gonna be
triggered okay oh well by the way then
there's also um
annabelle who passed away very
tragically last year that was crazy
very very tragically okay then there is
also who wait i need i'm sorry
sophie stanberry she she does like
bombay hair ads on instagram i don't
know if things are going as well for her
as they are for the other ladies but
i wish her well yeah hold on no i know
the woman's name but when i say this
one mapperton
oh god julie she was the woodiest
wot ever earl of sandwich she was the
worst
she was the worst but you know what like
as far as bravo shows go oh my god
i'm so glad you brought this up do you
know what i watched yesterday nyc prep
okay jackie are you okay after it
it was actually traumatizing like what a
piece of [ __ ] it was
first of all these kids are such losers
oh my god like the way they
like yeah i have money like yeah i have
a credit card with no limit like yeah
like you could die from how cringy it
was and like none of them were really
like cool or interesting and like they
just thought they were so
cool like i'm sure like it's the biggest
regret of their lives individually going
on that show because i did a lot of
research like where are they now
almost all of them live very private
lives like they don't really they're not
like instagram influencers like they
really like they all got married and
just like
i think that this is like a [ __ ] stain
on the
underwear of their life well i think
when they joined the show they thought
that they were going to be the real life
gossip girl they were going to be what
laguna beach was to the show the oc they
would be the lauren conrad of new york
city well
let me tell you why it could have never
been that none of them were
actually cool and two they made this
whole
cringy like divide between private
school and public school
because one of the main cast members
taylor goes to publix she's cute the
cutest and so nice and so like normal
except the way she spoke to her mom was
just so painful
um but like she would be like i mean
that's my ex-boyfriend from
public school and it's like really hard
it was it was really just like so
painful to watch
um but oh what i was saying is that like
so with nyc prep like they totally
miscast that show like none of those
people were
actually cool i'm sorry like a nice and
i stand by that some of them did have a
lot of money but that doesn't make you
cool like at all
yeah um so i feel like in a lot of these
types of shows
like they really miscast um
even in the real housewives of new york
like none of them if it weren't for the
show are really like well-known
socialites
or and i feel like in ladies of london
they like absolutely nailed it like
every single person was more interesting
than the next
they all had so much money they all had
the connections to royalty or
the london social scene like they were
all legitimately famous in london
and i'm really surprised that show
didn't work out well i think the reason
why it didn't work out
ultimately is because caroline stanberry
was like the kingpin of the show
and she moved out of london and they
also ran her out of town because they
were trying to take her down like they
turned her
style and i'm sorry just like that she's
she's not that like she's not so
fabulous like she was on another level
and they were like
trying to call her out for acting better
than them but it's like no no no she
just
is better yeah no also like that first
season where like she ran that fabulous
like gift guide company and she had like
that sickening office
and then like her like country home she
was really every and
they were all really everything of the
sort and they just got even caprice who
like i had never heard of she was famous
like
big time in london and i feel like the
show was so perfectly cast and i'm like
it makes me sad that it never got
picked up fully because it was like a
blimp on the radar honestly i think it
might be on peacock it's worth watching
if you've never seen it oh my god you
guys it is so
so good you're going to fall in love
with caroline stanberry follow her on
instagram and find out that she's got a
new man in her life
and she's super fabulous totally okay
fifth and final story is a little
entertainment biz news
hallmark channel names its next ceo
hallmark channel has found its next
leader former tv one chief
juanya lucas has been tapped to serve as
president and ceo
of crown media family networks a
subsidiary of hallmark cards inc
lucas who will begin her post on august
10th will report to hallmark
ceo mike perry lucas takes over the role
previously held by bill abbott
he was the executive who was pushed out
in january following a particularly
fraught holiday season
um when they removed that commercial
featuring a same-sex couple
that was so lame like if you're going to
approve the commercial just like approve
it
that was just that was like the most
poorly handled like media misfire
in the history of television agreed
lucas will be charged with accelerating
and growing hallmark tv's brand its
strategic direction day-to-day
management and growth of its three
linear networks
hallmark channel harmarc movies and
mysteries and hallmark drama
i'm unfamiliar with hallmark drama what
the article fails to know is that she is
a black woman
which i think will be fabulous because
hallmark movies are notoriously
you know very narrow in their casting
it's always like you know a small town
little white girl
and i think that there's a real
opportunity for growth here and i think
having a female black ceo is going to be
great for hallmark i totally agree she's
also a huge fan of hallmark she said
hallmark has been central to my life
since i can remember
starting with those hallmark hall of
fame movies that were as enriching as
they were
entertaining oh she sounds smart she
said i mean you know a hallmark stan is
is a stan of mine and or i'm a stan of a
hallmark stan
any hallmark stan i stan good
and so i'm so excited to see what she
does with hallmark you know
there's always room to grow and there's
a lot of legitimate criticism
surrounding the hallmark channel and so
i look forward
to a different sort of countdown to
christmas this year have you been
watching any christmas in july movies
you know what i turned one on the other
night but it was candace cameron beret
and i just
do not subscribe like there's no i have
no
tangible problem with her it's just like
she doesn't get me in the christmas
spirit i agree um so i i didn't continue
on
yeah um i don't know if i even get the
hallmark channel i literally i
only watch it when i'm like on vacation
with you yeah so i don't get the
hallmark channel on youtube tv but i
have all of the different apps the
hallmark
you know um the hallmark channel then
you have the home like
the movie subscription yeah and then
they have this app that has all these
different hallmark movies um
not always the ones that i that i want
to see but i make it work
you do make it work who was that um
hallmark star we interviewed on the red
carpet cma with the red hair
she was she's a star she's a classic
yeah who's your
like okay so if you turn on a hallmark
movie and you see candace cam and beret
like you're out
yeah um if you try to stick around for
yeah or
like who who else do you turn off
oh who else gretchen weiners would you
love gretchen
i really don't like any of the full
house people i know that they sent me to
like
stephanie and dj and they used to have
laurie oh they used to have lori
and they're all part of the hallmark
family i am not
into them i guess i'm just like not so
into full house i'm not either and i'm
definitely not into fuller house
yeah no i'm out on that but i would say
the people that i
really like are gretchen wieners
jessica loundis she's from sheba she's
she's from none of you know she's
sickeningly stunningly beautiful
sickeningly stunningly beautiful she's
been in a few uh
really good ones oh my god when i was at
hallmark
to do their podcast they i had said i
don't know on my
stories or on the show once that like i
was trying to watch becca tobin's
hallmark movies
and they gave me two flash drives with
all of her movies on them and i haven't
watched them so nice
she's perfect for it i know and like i
need to watch the becca tobin movie and
when we were on their podcast lady gang
or they were on ours we like asked her
what it was like and she said like
it is the last like network you can do a
movie for that treats you like a mega
star like the trailer she said it is
you're like you're so well taken care of
and it's like glamorous
old hollywood which you just love to
hear that they really take care of their
um
talent definitely it makes you just
stand
even harder and so i'm just i'm looking
forward to countdown to christmas
i haven't been participating in
christmas in july but
you never know it's never too late i
know that it's like kind of early but
i'm really excited for the holiday
season
i'm one of those people who like lives
for the holiday season when the holiday
season like
after christmas and like a little
afternoon years like i do get like in a
little bit of a slump like i just
i love like christmas in new york
i love all like the aesthetic i love
christmas trees like i really do
love the traditions and like the
cultural traditions of christmas because
like obviously we're jewish
um and i'm excited like i know that it's
it's already august so like we have you
know
halloween thanksgiving and then we're
there yeah it's exciting and we've been
in a slump all year
so i don't i'm not i don't fear the
post-christmas slump
right now and like if there's one time
of year where i wouldn't mind being
quarantined it would be like
a snowy christmas with like eggnog and a
tree right
it's just something to think about it's
gonna be a great anyways it's gonna be a
great hallmark season
yes thanks to their new ceo um okay
let's dive into the tv recap segment um
which is brought to you by our patreon
channel patreon.com
morningtoast if you are looking for more
episodes from us because monday through
friday is just not enough
you can pay 7.99 on our patreon channel
patreon.com and that eight dollars a
month will get you five extra episodes
jackie and i record videos on their
vlogs and we do regular podcast episodes
we take your requests for episodes
um if you sign up now you can get access
to all the episodes we've ever done on
there so it's like over 200 episodes so
it's really a great price
especially for the first month um and
then you also get access to the facebook
group associated with it which is our
current only active facebook group
um it's a toast after dark and it's such
a fabulous facebook group i highly
recommend it so
patreon.com thank you patreon for
sponsoring this segment yes okay should
we just recap beverly hills quickly
before
new york just tell me what your thoughts
were so my thoughts were
very similar to yours i thought it was a
great episode one of my favorite moments
was when garcelle and sutton went
to dinner and you know sutton started
off extremely weak and
and and strange and she's just become
just a great asset uh it would be nice
if she were a main cast member so we
could see more of her personal life like
we've never really seen
inside of her house but her boyfriend
like he just shows up places
yeah we don't know that much about her
but it's because i think bravo's telling
us like don't get invested in this woman
like she's not gonna be sticking around
because like her husband didn't sign the
paperwork right
uh so that's a bummer but i just i loved
the conversation between her and cartel
yeah but what did you think about
garcelle asking her how much money you
have where'd you get your money like
i i'm very um i'm like arcelic i'm not
afraid to ask questions but i don't
think i would ever ask someone that it
was weird
like i understood what she was saying
she's not asking like how much money do
you have it's
it's sort of like she could have asked a
million roundabout questions to arrive
at that
at that answer like is just where's your
your source of income that's kind of
like asking someone what do you do for
work you also like literally could have
googled it like that's how we found out
what sutton does for a living you know
what i mean
yeah it was weird i mean but that's also
true friendship like just being able to
ask
real questions i didn't think it was you
know it wasn't like
asking about money in the way that you
that's like the worst
kind of way to ask about it she was just
asking as a friend like listen i want to
be your friend just what
tell me your deal no i totally disagree
i thought it was so weird oh i
like i it didn't bother me did you find
like the setup for brandy to walk into
kyle's house to be so staged and weird
i did i did and i wonder
who put it all together you know if it
was kim talking to kyle saying brandi
has something that she needs to share
with the group
if it was producers who figured it out i
would like to know um and i also would
like for them to stop pretending
like these things are happening
naturally just be honest with us like
if just if kyle heard from kim that
brandi has something to say that affects
the groups like just say that
thousand percent like we're we're all
adults here agree we are
all adults we can handle the truth but
didn't did you get like a little choked
up
with with brandy like i really never saw
her be like so
raw and like open yeah i really felt for
her but then also you said that teddy
was like what the worst person she could
have told because she just like didn't
have and her mouth was like a gap
but i also felt like now teddy is in
charge of relying this information to
the rest of the group and i already see
how she's botching it oh yeah even in
the way
like she was telling lisa reyna like the
second day like wait till you get to the
hotel
yeah and also like the story isn't
necessarily about the fact that
brandy and denise hooked up you know
because
that's their personal business it's the
way that denise like made
like kind of lied to brandy and said
that it's about made it into a fair
between br between denise and aaron and
is it open or is it not
if it's not then denise cheated it's not
so much like
they hooked up you know it's the she
made like
it's the surrounding circumstances that
just speak to the fact that maybe denise
isn't who they think she is right um
do you think that brandy was lying when
she relayed all the information that
denise like all the [ __ ] denise
allegedly talked about the women like
she's trying to get out of her dad's
shadow erica's a cold-hearted [ __ ] like
do you think that stuff was real
i do think it was real because her
saying that about teddy like what's
where's the lie um her saying that and i
think she said that about rina after
their latest conversation and after she
realized rana is not a friend to her no
she's not so yeah i don't like lisa rana
that seems i don't know what the crime
is there
and then it did make me sad that she had
that to say about erica
me too but maybe even that could have
been just sort of like a
miscommunication where she's just like
well eric was cold you know and and it
goes from being cold to cold hearted
[ __ ]
yeah i i just don't see what brandy
would get out of lying about any of this
so i really do believe everything she
said
me too but then there is also you know
there it's not even that i think she
might be lying but
from denise's point of view things might
be different which is why it's worth
you know hearing her just because brandi
said one thing that's her perception of
everything and
and that's her like her perception of
the things that denise said about the
other women and
if you if you were to ask denise and she
were to explain it like
it wouldn't be so harsh perhaps
so i'm the jury's still out for me and
denise on watch weapons live um
ted uh not teddy darite was on and andy
said
lisa arena tweeted that the reunion was
[ __ ] do you agree and jarite said no
so i feel like lisa arena might like get
it a little bit at the reunion for
something
interesting from what i understood it
was rina was pissed because i guess they
can't really talk about the denise stuff
or they can't talk about something so
it's [ __ ] if we're gonna have
reunion
and not mention at all i feel that
hardcore but if jury didn't feel that
way but also
we know that dory is a denise stan
stan apologist and might be feeling like
no
this isn't appropriate for us to talk
about that way like therefore it's not
[ __ ] right
you know i actually like that doreen um
seems to like
really be staying in the middle of it
all while also being supportive of
denise and like making denise feel like
she's not 100 isolated from the group
yeah so it was a good episode right
no it was a really good episode
definitely makes you think definitely
sets it up for a great
trip trip and
yeah i mean it'll be interesting to see
how denise
figures it out but like what they were
trying to
the overarching argument is like denise
is not who she says she is she pretends
to be one person on the show when she is
like
a whole other person in real life and i
just
i don't think it's that simple you know
me neither and i don't think if that was
were true like that's the craziest thing
ever like and the person that denise was
last season like she was so laid back so
casual like she really didn't
care i liked that about her a lot and i
don't think that she was putting on now
they're trying to make this divide
between like
she you know was covering up her last
season where she was like so open
and now she wants to seem more you know
conservative and talk about the children
and i just i don't see that way she was
super open when the kids weren't around
now the kids are around so we gotta just
tamper it down but you know who is doing
that like
using this season of the show to like
change their image is
ramona singer i really saw such a
parallel in the two episodes the one
from last night and then the
episode of beverly hills because ramona
has decided i'm transitioning to new
york now
ramona has decided that she no longer
wants to be like this trash
drunk um like what the really what the
show has been for the last few seasons
like messy older women
being messy and she has now decided that
she's gonna elevate it but she didn't
tell anyone of her plans
and she is like really um
being annoying about it yeah okay i feel
like people are not gonna like what i
have to say about last night's episode
of real houses in new york because as
much as like ramona
is as much as i personally would do what
leah was doing at her party and dance
and you know
ramona was being dramatic like the way
that the women were talking about her
the day of her party like leading up to
your party like
why are you going to celebrate this
woman and the fact that when you look at
it and everybody dressed came in the
dress code for ramona and the women just
completely ignored it they have
absolutely no respect for her it's like
why are you there and i feel like for
ramona it's like listen you girls are my
co-workers you're
my like trashy co-workers and you're not
my real friends and i understood now why
last year she didn't invite any of the
girls she did not want that mess
of course and i totally agree i think
like dorinda luanne and sonia sitting in
the corner of the party being like
she didn't wish me a happy birthday on
instagram and this parties that even for
me
two-year-old they're so wrong if ramona
wants to throw herself a lavish birthday
party
she has every right to do so even though
the party ended up looking so trashy
like all the red it was so terrible
um them literally like stewing in the
corner about the instagram post and the
larry scott
get over it and the fact that like
ramona threw herself a birthday party
and didn't pay for it for sonia two
that is so unreasonable and i agree like
they were acting like animals at the
party they were acting like animals and
i'm not talking about the leah dancing
artist everything before that the day of
like they're in dorinda's kitchen just
talking [ __ ] about ramona and then it's
like you wonder why she doesn't want you
around
who she who she considers to be her real
friends like what
what's the big mystery there a hundred
percent i totally agree
and like even when she came over with
the purse and they're like that purse is
they're just so [ __ ] rude and it's
like okay maybe the purse is ugly maybe
ramona isn't
i felt like purse was pretty have some i
thought that purse was fine too
have some decency like you're still in a
public event like
no they have no self-awareness no
self-awareness and then when sonia is
like stepping on the
on the glass tree third thing like
you're proving you're proving ramona to
be right right and that's exactly what
leah was saying on watch
watchtrap and live was so weird last
night because they had i watched the
first five minutes and i could see what
was going on the comedian michelle
bouteau who's very funny but who
obviously like
i just don't think like she likes leah
and she wasn't she wasn't on lea's side
no for anything and she like kept like
contradicting leah
and like um like almost calling her out
it was and i think leah like wasn't
expecting it because the first time she
did it
like leah was very caught off guard but
it's obvious that
michelle is like a huge housewives fan
and has like
knows all the history knows all the
knowledge and
really forms strong opinions on it and
she wasn't on leah's side at all
yeah and i think also for leah it feels
like she's on watch what happens live
every week every year i don't think
anyone in quarantine has been on watch
what happens i'm
at home more than leah i agree and i
think her the response to leah from the
show has been
completely overwhelmingly positive like
i don't know of any housewife who has
made such a good first impression on the
fellow housewives
and the fans agreed and i think this was
really the first time where someone told
leah like they didn't agree with her
and she was so not expecting she was
just taken aback because every week she
comes and watch what happens live and
like
leah we love you so fabulous for someone
to be like actually like it's ramona's
party it's ramona's rules
right she didn't really know what to do
what i felt bad for leah was
that like she's new into this group and
as far as she knows like these are just
a bunch of animals who literally get
wasted
fall off of chairs in the berkshires and
just do crazy things so i don't know if
leah was really
made aware that like this party had to
be very different
and i think that like she just tries to
get along with the group and she
follows the lead of the group and the
group is like a bunch of drunken messes
like running around new york
and so that's what she was doing and
while i the dancing was definitely like
a little inappropriate ramona like being
like cut the cameras i'm quitting
she's so dramatic yeah and it's like
it's a birthday party and your
your real friends know they see the show
it's on tv like
they know that you guys are a bunch of
messy
messers and it's not really like a
secret but ramona trying to just like
immediately rebrand herself in two
seconds like that's not how a rebrand
works
yeah no it's not but okay so maybe
that's what she was trying to do last
season which is why she didn't have the
women at her birthday party
and then she shouldn't have had her ass
handed to her because of that clip
and now you know what i understand why
she said because if sonia came that
would mean cameras are coming
yep and and she doesn't want to be this
person all of the time
so this year she invited the girls and i
think in her
way that i don't approve of when she was
like doing the tour with lee and she's
like you need to protect me like i was
like
cringe who cares but what she was trying
to
she was trying to make that distinction
i agree and
it completely backfired and it like fell
flat nobody
see the thing with the ramona is like
she's a near perfect reality star
but what is ruining her and and has been
a problem for her throughout the years
is that she like lives two lives
and she has these 50 girlfriends who are
all like very wealthy upper east side
women
and they would never go on housewives
and they don't necessarily like approve
of the housewives
and so ramona time after time every
season especially around her birthday
tries to keep those two worlds separate
and they're hard to keep separate
because jorinda knows a lot of the women
uh sonia knows a lot of the women and
sonia just like crying all night that
she introduced these women to ramona is
so annoying
sonia was really annoying me last night
she was acting like a beast also
i wanted to mention this when dorinda
was like
being there for sonia it proves one like
so much everything that we've been
saying about dorinda this season like
when someone is doing well
dorinda just like has it out for them
but like she's so sweet to sonia because
like sonia is clearly struggling so like
when tin with tinsley with luanne like
when any time that luanne is doing well
and not
shy about it she completely goes for the
jugular with luanne but because sonia is
in such a fragile state
and and dorinda like literally gets off
on sonia like
sharing her despair with her oh and she
draws it out of her like even when sonya
i feel like they were making it a much
bigger deal like sonya getting kicked
out of a bar
is not the craziest thing the way that
these women behave they're always in
like a home or a private setting but
all of their behavior is working is
worthy like leah with the torches
and the swimming and the berkshires and
the throwing like they're always worthy
of being
it's probably the first time she was
just in a public place doing what she
always does
thousand percent and i feel like jorinda
was trying so hard to make it seem like
sony's going through something
i don't think she's really going she has
a leak in the basement yeah no it's just
like dorindo
likes to be in charge and so if that
makes sonya feel small being like what
are you going through
and talking to all the women about it
before i didn't think there was really
anything going on with sonya
i wasn't that surprised that she got
kicked out of a bar no i didn't think
there was much going on with sonya other
than the usual stressors of life
the town having a townhouse and having
to do all the things that she needs to
do about it but that's not
like that's a situational issue agreed
you know
i i think dorinda is like looking for
you know a bigger
issue because that's what she likes she
likes to see other people down so she
can like
feel bigger so she can come up and like
be maternal and then when someone is big
and doing well she has to attack them
she's really one of my least favorites i
go i swing so back and forth with her
because
sometimes she's like so funny and so
like nails it and it's on the right side
of history
but most of the time she's an animal who
like literally says the most below the
belt mean things to people
and i really never agree with her
decision making yeah me either and she
finds a way to make people feel bad for
ramona
like yes the the toast at halloween it's
like
ramona needs no help you know she
is like says like she is just so
outlandish and
she and she holds her own and but to
ever it is a true skill to make someone
feel bad for ramona
agreed and you know what i i i agree
with a lot of what you said
i'm not like completely turnt on ramona
like all the other women are and when
they go to mexico next week
i think it escalates because really the
only big fight right now is literally
the world versus ramona
and i don't agree with that i don't
agree with i think that sonia
acted very very poorly at the party and
ramona had every right to be upset i do
think she took it out on leah which she
shouldn't have she shouldn't have
but how yeah i i don't i don't it's not
so cut and dry i'm not team everyone or
team ramona
i part of me did feel bad for a mother
she worked so hard to make this like a
nice event like there wasn't even a
dance floor it was a
like a dinner so she she had made very
intentional decisions for it not to turn
into like a rowdy
mess and it obviously ended up yeah i
it's like i see whatever what the women
say about ramona like i see how she
is all of those things but then they
make it worse and you find yourself in a
place where it's like
listen ramona's still a person this is
her [ __ ] birthday party like behave
yeah agreed so but i thought it was a
great episode actually and i cannot wait
i love when the new york women go to
mexico it is just everything of the
story yeah i'm really looking forward we
have two cast trips next week like
oh yeah rome and mexico so
oh my god i wish i was in mexico oh my
god um it was a good bravo week and a
good week here at the toast
anything else you want to say before we
wrap up for friday
no we shall see you on monday thank you
guys so much for listening to the
morning toast millennium morning show we
post videos on youtube monday through
friday
and our videos are also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cast box
all the places my comedy special is
still available if you go to the
instagram
story highlight on girl with no job
there's a story highlight called
disgraced queen
and you can find all the links there to
places you could buy rent and stream at
my comedy album
and my comedy special i appreciate all
the support this far and i hope you guys
are enjoying the content as much as i've
been
enjoying the content of you watching the
content um that's all she wrote
thank you guys so much have a fabulous
weekend we'll see you on monday goodbye
you